[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشخلي
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور تاتي مباشره من
العاصمه اللثوانيه عشيه القمه المرتقبه
ويتحدث الان رئيس الوزراء السويدي مع
حديثا عن اتفاق مع تركيا بشان تمرير عضويه
السويد في
والان هذه اللقطات من الكنيست الاسرائيليه
ومناقشه بنود في التعديلات القضائيه التي
تثير الجدل والاحتجاجات في وجه حكومه
نتنياهو
كذلك هذه مشاهد تاتي مباشره من ايسلندا
وبدا ثوران احد البراكين هنا
وفي مواضيع الحساد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
بعد نقاشات خيمت على تحضيرات قمه النيتو
بشان حصول تركيا على الدعم لعضويه الاتحاد
الاوروبي مقابل قبولها بعضويه السويد في
النيتو يؤكد موافقه اردوغان على احاله
الملف لبرلمان بلاده ومسؤول تركي يؤكد
تلقي دعم لمشاريع عضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي
ورفع العقوبات وتسهيل التاشيرات
لقاء مرتقب غدا بين الرئيسين الامريكي
والتركي وبايدن يتحدث عن تعزيز التعاون
الدفاعي
[موسيقى]
تصاعد خلاف سوداني افريقي من بوابه
الايجاد بعد مقاطعه الوفد الحكومي
السوداني الاجتماعات في اديس ابا واتهام
نيروبي بالانحياز الرئيس الكيني يتحدث عن
ضروره تشكيل قياده سودانيه جديده ورئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبي يطالب بفرض منطقه حظر
طيران في السودان ونزع المدفعيه ثقيله
تمهيدا لوقف اطلاق النار
تصف الوضع بالمقلق للغايه وتقول انه لا حل
عسكريا للصراع
على ارضيه تصعيد مستمر كتيبه العياش في
مخيم جنين تعلن اطلاق الصاروخين محليي صنع
على مستوطنه شكيب الجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد
العثور على الشظايا ومنصتي اطلاق ويعلن
فتحه تحقيق ورئيس مجلس مستوطنات شمال
الضفه يدعو لاطلاق عمليه عسكريه واسعه
[موسيقى]
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا قمه المرتقبه في ليتوانيا
حيث تتسارع النقاشات بشان ملفات عده احد
اهم الملفات كانت قضيه انضمام السويد
للحلف انضمام كادت ان تحول دونه تركيا
ولكن تسرعت الاحداث جاءت الموافقه من
انقره على انضمام السويد مقرونه بتاكيد عن
تلقي دعم لفتح الطريق امامها لعضويه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وكنا استطلعنا اراءكم
بشان هذا الموضوع وطرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي هل ستحضر سويد بعطويه النيتو
53% قالوا نعم مقابل الاستجابه للطلبات
التركيه في المقابل قال
47% لا بسبب التباينات
اذا هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا ومتفاعله عربيا
[موسيقى]
قال الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي ينسى
قبل قمه الحلف التي ستنطلق في فينيوس ان
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وافق على
احاله طلب السويده لانضمام الى البرلمان
التركي وقد عبر استوتنبرغ عن سروره
بموافقه اردوغان على احاله بروتوكول
انضمام السويد الى البرلمان التركي في
اقرب وقت ممكن والعمل عن كثب مع المجلس
لضمان التصديق عليه وقال استوتنبرغ ان
السويد ستدعم جهود تنشيط عمليه انضمام
تركيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي بما في ذلك
الاتحاد الجمركي واعفاء الاتراك من تاشيره
وقد نقلت وكاله الاناضول عن مسؤول تركي
رفيع ان تركيا تلقى الدعما كاملا لمساريع
عضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي ورفع العقوبات
وتحرير التاش
ومعنا الان من فينوس ومراسل الجزيره محمد
المدهون محمد اذا واضح ان هناك تطورات
سريعه في الساعات الاخيره حدثنا عن
التفاصيل
نعم ليلى يوم تاريخي لحل في شمال الاطلسي
كما وصفه الامين العام للحلف في مؤتمره
الصحفي بعد اجتماع ما بين الرئيس التركي
ورئيس الحكومه السويديه باشراف وبوساطه
وبرعايه من الامين العام للحلف هذا
الاجتماع الذي استمر ساعات وبدا بين
الرجال الثلاثه وحدهم ثم انضم اليهم
مسؤولون من الطرفين السويدي والتركي وزراء
الخارجيه ومسؤولون امنيون وانقطع هذا
الاجتماع لدقائق حقيقه عندما غادر الرئيس
التركي هذا الاجتماع وتوجه للقاء رئيس
المجلس الاوروبي شارميشيل
ليتلقى بعض الضمانات بشان مستقبل عضويه
تركيا في الاتحاد الاوروبي على ما يبدو
هذا ما فهمناه من المؤتمر الصحفي الذي
اعلنت فيه الامين العام لحلف في شمال
الاطلسي ان الرئيس اردوغان وافق على احاله
طلب السويد الى الحلف
للبرلمان التركي في اقرب وقت ممكن كما قال
وتعهد
بدعم هذا الطلب والعمل مع المجلس عن كثب
للموافقه على طلب السويد اذا هو قرار
سياسي كان الحلف يامل بان يتوصل اليه من
الرئيس التركي وقد توصل اليه بالفعل صحيح
ان هناك عمليه اجرائيه قد تتطلب وقتا
اضافيا ولكن على الاقل قرار سياسي عشيه
هذه القمه التاريخيه بانضمام عضو جديد
للاسره الاطلسيه العضو الثاني
والثلاثين وهو السويد في المقابل تركيا
حصلت على بعض الضمانات من السويد المتعلقه
هي حقيقه مكتسبات يمكن وصفها بالامنيه
والاقتصاديه والاستثماريه والتجاريه على
المدى الطويل ولن تنتهي بانضمام السويد
الى الحلف يؤكد البيان الصادر عن الامين
العام للناتو بان تعهد السويد بمكافحه
الارهاب هو تعهد طويل المدى ولم ينتهي
بانضمام استوكهولم الى الحلف بل ان الحلف
نفسه سيعين لاول مره في تاريخه منسقا خاصا
لمكافحه الارهاب والحلف كحلف ويؤيد هذه
المخاوف الامنيه المشروع لتركيا وسيعمل مع
الطرفين وذكر ايضا ان السويد وتركيا
ستوقعان اتفاقيه امنيه بموجبها سيجتمع
المسؤولون
على مستوى الوزراء هذا الاتفاقيه الامنيه
تنص على اجتماع سنوي على مستوى الوزراء ما
بين السويد وتركيا وتشكيل مجموعات عمل
لمعالجه المخاوف التركيه بشان ما تصفها
بالمجموعات الارهابيه تحديدا حز ب العمال
الكردستاني في السويد والناشطين في هذا
فضلا عن دعم السويد لمسار انضمام تركيا
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي بما في ذلك العمل
ودعم الجهود لتحرير التاشيرات على
المواطنين الاتراك وكذلك تحديث الاتحاد
الجمركي الذي يربط تركيا بالاتحاد
الاوروبي اشكرك جزيلا محمد المدهون من
فيلاس شكرا جزيلا
لم تحصل تركيا على شيء
ربما قد تكون مقاتلات الاف سته عشر التي
كانت تطلبها تركيا من الولايات المتحده
لقد سبق لنا
ان دفعنا ثمن طائرات الاف خمسه عشر ولم
تعد لنا الولايات المتحده
المال ربما استخدم بايدن سياسه الجزره
والعصا ربما قال يجب ان توافقوا على
انضمام السويد الى الحلف وانا سوف اعمل من
اجل ان امنه لكم
طائرات 2016 اما بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي
فتركي سوف لن تحصل على شيء هذه كلمات
ووعود فارغه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعض
الكثير من الدول الاعضاء وكلها سوف تعترض
على كل ما وعدت به تركيا ما يمكن للسويد
ان تقوم به حتى تساعد تركيا بالنسبه الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا شيء سوف لن يخرج شيء
من ذلك
وتركيا اذا تركيا المتحده تحل هذا الملف
الى البرلمان الان دون ان تحصل على مقابل
لا شيء هذه التسهيلات التي حصلت عليها في
البرلمان الاوروبي لا تعني شيء بالنسبه
لتركيا
هناك خدعه بسيطه هنا بعد التحدث الى بايدن
قال اردوغان
اذا
كان يؤمن موافقه الكونجرس هو دائما يحدثنا
عن صلاحيته في الكونجرس
نحن ايضا لدينا الكونجرس الوطني الخاص بنا
وهو الذي لديه التاثير هذا يعني
ان
اذا حلفاء حزب اردوغان قد يقولون
ربما اردوغان الذي وافق ولكن نحن سوف لن
نوافق
وبالتالي يمكنه
اذا او يمكن ان يعرقل الموضوع في البرلمان
التركي
الصفقه لم تحسم بعد هذا مهم وضحت فكرتك
اريد ان اسال سيد مايكل ريان بهذا الخصوص
ما قراءتك انت لاحداث الساعه الاخيره هل
فعلا
الصفقه اصبحت بالجيب السويد الان ستصبح
عضو برايك
نعم انا اعتقد ان السويد سوف تصير عضوا في
النيتو انا اوافق سعاده السفير ان هذه
الصفقه لم تستكمل الى حين ان تظهر الوقائع
الميدانيه ان الوعود فعلا سوف تحقق
البرلمان تركي لديه دور والرئيس اردوغان
كان لديه اكثر من سنه للتفاوض مع السويد
والنيتو والاتحاد الاوروبي اعتقد انه خلال
هذا الوقت تم التوصل الى اتفاق على
التحصيل افضل صفقه وعلى هذا الاساس يمضي
الناتو تحالف وتركيا من ابرز اعضائه ومن
مصلحه تركيا ان يمضي الحلف قدما مع وجود
السويد عضوا فيه
ولكن السؤال الاكبر مقابل ماذا
سيد
مايكل مقابل ماذا
انه سؤال وجيه بالنسبه الى اراضي السويد
فهي في وسط اسكندنافيا هذا يعني ان كل
الجزء الشمالي من اوروبا سوف يصير ضمنه حل
شمال اطلسي من وجهه نظر الدفاع عن دول
اعضاء في الناتيه مع دول البلطيق المعرضه
لاشتياح روسيا فان القوى البحريه والجويه
التابعه للحلف يمكنها ان تتحرك في شمال
اوروبا
انا اسالك يعني مقابل ماذا يمكن ان تقدم
تركيا هذا هذه التنازلات كما ذكرت حتى
يوافق البرلمان لا نعرف فعلا اذا كان
الامر مقضيا ولكن اسالك ما الذي يجعل
رجب طيب اردوغان يدفع بهذا الاتجاه الان
ما الذي سيحصل عليه في المقابل برايك
نعم شكرا على التوضيح هو قد اثبت انه من
ابرز رجال الدوله في اوروبا وفي شمال
الاطلسي حين وافق على الصفقه بالنسبه الى
السويد هذا اولا اوافق سعاده السفير ان
طائرات 16
لتعزيز القوات الجويه التركيه هي مهمه جدا
لتركيا كونها جزءا اساسيا من الناتو هذا
يعزز من هيبه اردوغان في الناتو في اوروبا
بما فيه ايضا تعزيز القوه التركيه
العسكريه اذا تمكن الاتحاد الاوروبي من
الحصول على توافق بين دول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد لمنح المواطنين على اتراك قدره
السفر الى اوروبا بدون فيزا بدون تاشيره
وادخال تركيا ضمنه منطقه الشانجان هذا
مفيد لتركيا واعتقد ان البرلمان في هذه
الحاله سوف يدعم السفير ايضا نورهان حسب
معرفتك انت بالاجراءات الشكليه كما وصفتها
قبل قليل ما قيمه فعلا احاله هذا الملف
الى البرلمان في هذا التوقيت والكل مجتمع
في ليتوانيا الان ويرتقب اعلان من نوع ما
اعلان وخرق فيما يتعلق بانضمام السويد
للنيتو
هذا هو جوهر المساله
هل سوف يصادق البرلمان التركي على هذا
الاتفاق هنا مربط الفرس بالتحديد ولابد من
ان نناقشه ان الاساس هنا هو الحزب الشريك
لحزب الحركه الوطنيه وقد يرفض القيام بذلك
هذا امر ضروري بالنسبه الى الجميع يجب ان
يدركه ان هذا حزب الحركه الوطنيه قد يرفض
الصفقه ليست محسومه
وتقول السويد
ان محاكمنا تترك لهؤلاء الارهابيين فرصه
الحركه في الشارع مع ان الشرطه طلب
توقيفهم وسجنهم ولكن ديمقراطيه يعني قضيه
تعيين منسق منسق معني بشؤون الارهاب في
حلف الناتو الا يعد هذه خطوه متقدمه من
جانب النيتو كمن يعني يقدم شيء مقابل ربما
والطمنت تركيا بهذا الاتجاه
لا لا قيمه لذلك فعلا لا قيمه لذلك صدقوني
سوف ترون ذلك هؤلاء الارهابيون سوف يكونون
في الشوارع السويديه وسوف يستمرون بعملهم
في كل مكان في اوروبا لا يعيدون تسليمهم
الى تركيا الولايات المتحده لا تسلمهم
الدول الاوروبيه فرنسا المانيا لا تسلمهم
بالتالي
هذا لا قيمه له صدقوني سوف ترون ام العين
السيد مايكل راين تسليم الطائرات الان اف
16 هل يمكن ايضا القول انه اصبح امر مسلم
الان
بسبب هذا الموقف الجديد من اردوغان هل
سيتم اعلان جديد تعتقد ان يحصل في
ليتوانيا ام علينا ان ننتظر ايضا حتى تصدر
النتيجه من البرلمان
حاليا لا يمكن ان نعرف حاليا الرئيس
اردوغان يعتقد انه يمكنه ان يحقق هذا
العضويه او ان يدعم عضويه السويد ولكن
مثلا السياسه الداخليه مختلفه بالنسبه الى
مقاتلات الافته عشر حاولت الولايات
المتحده ان تفصل نقاش حول مقاتله 16 عن
نقاش عضويه السويد في النيتو اذا حصل
اتفاق حتى الان لم يحصل فان اي تحرك
بالنسبه الى طائرات الاف سته عشر ستحصل
بعد
القمه وتكون قد اتضحت صوره موقف تركي او
حتى التقدم في ملف انضمام السويد الى
الحلف اشكرك من ولايه
مساعد سابق لوزير الدفاع لسياسه الاوروبيه
والسياسه النيتو وشكرا جزيلا من ازمير
لايدن نورهان السفير السابق في الخارجيه
تركيا
[موسيقى]
اذا اختتمت قمه الاليه الرباعيه لمجموعه
الاجازه التي انعقدت في العاصمه الاثيوبيه
لبحث صور حل الصراع في السودان البيان
والختامي للقمه دعا طرفي الصراع الى الوقف
الفوري لاطلاق النار والاحتكام للحوار
والتفاوض مشددا انه لا حل عسكريا للصراع
كما دعى البيان الى البدء في فتح ممرات
انسانيه امنه لايصال المساعدات وكان وفد
الجيش السوداني قد غاب عن القمه بينما
حضرها وفد من القيادات السياسيه والمدنيه
السودانيه اضافه الى ممثلين عن قوات الدعم
السريع وتمسكت الحكومه السودانيه برفض
المشاركه في الاجتماع بسبب تراس كينيا
للجلسات ونظرا لما وصفته بعدم حياد الرئيس
الكيني ويليام روتو في الازمه السودانيه
يبدو ان التاريخ يعيد وقايعه بشكل ماساوي
في السودان فالتحرك الذي انخرطت فيه قوه
سياسيه سودانيه بعد ان افاقت من صدمه
الحرب وحساب الربح والخساره هذا التحرك
يسلق الطرق القديمه نفسها لوقف الحرب
وتحقيق السلام دون الوقوف عند سؤال لما
قامت الحرب
وتنهض في هذا السعي الشخصيات نفسها التي
نشات الحرب في كنف فعلها السياسي واليوم
يزداد الامر سوءا بتدخل افريقي لن يقبل به
السودان الذي انسحب وفده من قمه الايجاد
فالمجموعه الافريقيه تشكك في قياده البلاد
وتدعو الى تدخل عسكري لوقف الحرب يسبقه
حظر للطيران موقف بدا مرتبا له في كلمات
رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي والرئيس الكيني
لقد اختتمنا للتو اجتماع الايجاد بشان
السودان اتفقنا جميعا على ان الوضع بلغ
حدا يرثى له وهذا يتطلب قياده طارئه
وقادره على اخراج السودان من الكارثه
الانسانيه التي يتجه اليها
من الواضح هي ان هناك فراغا في القياده في
السودان ولا يمكننا ان نقف مكتوفي الايدي
فالعواق موسى ستكون وخيمه على المنطقه
باكملها لذلك نحن بحاجه الى تمهيد الطريق
لاتخاذ اجراءات فوريه حيث يتعين على طرفي
النزاع وقف اطلاق نار غير مشروط وغير محدد
على الفور ولهذا الغرض ندعو الى منطقه حظر
طيران فوق السودان ونزع المدفعيه الثقيله
وتسهيل ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
جميع المتضررين واستئناف الحوار السياسي
غرابه هذه الدعوه انها تاتي من رئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبي الذي رفض مجرد طاعات
الاتحاد الافريقي في الشان
حرب قادها ابي احمد ضد اثنيه التجراي
المتمرده اما الوفد المدني السوداني الذي
يضم اعضاء في مجلس السياده وقياديين في
احزابهم ومسؤولين سابقين في حكومه عبد
الله حمدوك الاولى والذي يبدو مباركا
قرارات الايجاد فقد بدا بزياره اوغندا
ولقاء الرئيس يوريم وسفينه للتفاكر حول
سبل وقف الحرب وربما الاستئناس بتجربه
اوغندا في التحول الديمقراطي وقد انتهى
الوفد عند اديس ابابا حيث الاتحاد
الافريقي وحيث رئيس الوزراء ابي احمد
والرئيس الكيني وثيق الصله بقائد التمرد
في السودان الجنرال محمد حمدان دقلو وتبدو
القوه السياسيه المدنيه الطوافه بشكايتها
من الحرب الى الزعماء الافارقه في اديس
ابابا امام معضله حقيقيه فهي تمد الجسورها
مع الخارج لوقف الحرب وحل مشكله السودان
السياسيه دون اعتبار للفاعلين في الصراع
داخل البلاد وهو ما يشي بغفله عن الظروف
الموضوعيه التي انشات الحرب بسبب اختلالات
ما كانت تخفى في المنظومه العسكريه او في
الاداء السياسي غير المنتج هنا اخر اجتماع
ضم القوى السياسيه المدنيه مع القوه
العسكريه المستبده بالامر في حفل توقيع
الاتفاق السياسي الايطالي في الخامس من
ديسمبر 2022 انه الاتفاق الذي مثل الوصفه
السحريه بين الدعم السريع وبين القوه
المدنيه المؤيده له اما المستوى الدولي
والاقليمي ممثلين في اللجنه الرباعيه من
الامارات والسعوديه وبريطانيا والولايات
المتحده والثلاثيه المكونه من الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد فهي
دعمت الاتفاق وتكفلت برعايه تنفيذه ومنحه
البراءه الديمقراطيه
وايما كان الامر فان لكل حرب مترتبات ومن
مترتبات الحرب الجاريه اليوم ان الاتفاق
الايطالي قد اصبح من الماضي واصابه ما
اصاب غيره من اشياء في هذه البلاد
فليس الدعم السريع اليوم هو الدعم السريع
امسي ولاحم حيثما وجد هو حمايه الذي كان
ولا الطبقه السياسيه هي الطبقه حتى الناطق
الرسمي باسم العمليه السياسيه كف عن ان
يكون ناطقا باسمها لانه لا وجود لها
ثم تواقع جديد سيخرج من كل هذا الركام من
ركام العسكريه ومن ركام السياسه
وصناع واقع الغد لن يكونوا في راي معظم
السودانيين هم من صنعوا بؤس الامس وشقاء
اليوم
ومعنى الان في الاستديو الكاتب والمحلل
السوداني ضياء الدين بلال ومن اديس اببا
فهد محمد الباحث في الشان الافريقي اهلا
بكما في الحساد وابدا معك سيد ضياء الدين
بلال اذا
كان يفترض ان يكون بوابه الحل اصبح بوابه
الخلاف
اي مبادره من الايجاد الان هي غير مقبوله
وتؤدي الى زياده خلافات ليس فقط سودانيا
انما الان بين السودان ودول افريقيا اخرى
كيف نفهم ما يجري هذه التعقيدات التشوهات
المرتبطه بالايجاد حتى الموقف الرباعي
الذي الذي كان من المفترض ان يكون منسجم
في هذه في هذه المبادره هو منقسم على نفسه
الان هنالك غياب للرئيس الجيبوتي وهنالك
غياب لرئيس دوله جنوب السودان ومن خلال
التصريحات التي صدرت اليوم من ابي احمد
رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي الذي يطالب بمنعه
استخدام الطائرات وهو الرجل نعم وهو الرجل
الذي قتل اكثر من 100 الف بالطائرات في
التجراي وهو الرجل الذي رفض التدخل
الايجاد ورفض التدخل الاتحاد الافريقي
والتجى الى جنوب افريقيا هذه هي المتناظات
هذه هي المتناقضات نحن نريد ان نناقش اذا
كان فعلا هذا يمكن ان يكون التي توضح بان
هنالك خلل اساسي في المنظومه منظومه
الايجاد من خلال الغياب ومن خلال هذا
التناقض ومن هذا خلال هذه المفارقات هذا
يوضح بان هذا المنبر غير مؤهل لايجاد حلول
لهذه الازمه وهو كما وصفه
السودانيه ليس اكثر ولا اقل والتصريحات
توشي بذلك التشريحات حتى التصريح الذي صدر
من الرئيس الكيني اليوم تحدث بانه يجب
قياده جديده كيف يمكنك ان تسعى للتوسط بين
اطراف وتزعا لفيزات الوقت لاقصاء وابعاد
هذه الاطراف واعتقد ان هنالك خلل بنيوي في
هذه
المبادره لا يجعلها قادره على ان تنمو
وتستمر هذه الفكره لفهد محمد هو معنى الان
من اديس ابابا
المبادرات الحلول التي قدمت هل فعلا راعت
التركيبه الخصوصيه المعقده للشان السوداني
في هذه المرحله
شكرا على استضافتكم الطيبه تحياتي لك
ولساده المشاهدين ونضيفك الكريم
طبعا للاسف الشديد عندما نرى اجتماعا
هو امتداد الاجتماع جيبوتي هذا اليوم وكان
هدف الرئيسي هو الجمع بين القوى السياسيه
او قاده القوى السياسيه لحل الازمه
السودانيه
ولم ينجح ذلك ربما وعدم وجود كل الاطراف
المتنازعه في هذا الاجتماع يعني يضع
الشكوك في للاسف الشديد يضع الشكوك في هذه
المبادره التي وضعتها الايجاد ويجب ان
ترتب اوراقها من جديد لتكون قوه فاعله في
هذه المبادره اذا ما الذي كان يمكن ان
تفعله بشكل مختلف السيد محمد السيد فهد
طبعا مراعاه شروط كل الاطراف لاننا في
ازمه ويعني الحل ربما يعني الوضع يتفاقم
سوءا والمدنيين يتضررون القصف يتزايد فعلى
هذه على مثل هذه المبادرات ربما ان تعطي
اولويه لكافه اطراف الصراع يعني على الاقل
يكون هناك وجهه نظر وتقارب
ولا يجب ان يكون هناك ربما
لا نقول انها تصفيه خلافات وعلى الاطراف
ايضا التفاهم ان المتضرر الاول والاخير هو
السودان يعني ويجب ان تكون
توافق توافق السيد ضياء الدين بلال في هذه
النقطه ولكن السؤال في النهايه اذا لم يكن
الاتحاد الافريقي لم تكن ليجاد هي الطرف
الذي يمكن ان يقدم الحلول والان وسط كل
هذه المعمعه
ما هي الوجهه من هو الطرف الذي يمكن فعلا
ان يتدخل بنزهه ويقدم الحلول للاسف معظم
التدخلات التي تاتي هي التدخلات غير حكيمه
وغير حميده الى حد كبير جدا حتى التدخل
الاساسي الذي اشعل هذا الحرب هل كان هنالك
تدخل من الرباعي ومن الثلاثيه من اطراف
امميه قدمت مقترح ادى الى اشعال التناقضات
بين المكونات العسكريه
مؤشرتي اليه قبل قليل بعدم معرفه دقائق
السياسه السودانيه وهذه التركيبه
الكيميائيه المعقده داخل السودان تجعل
الكثير من الحلول التي تقدم تؤدي الى الى
نقيض ما هو مراد تؤدي الى الاشتعال وتؤدي
اعتقد ان يكون من الداخل تحدث
سودانيه وطنيه تلاحظ هذا هذه هذه الجرائم
وتلاحظ هذا الخراب وتلاحظ هذا الدمار
وتتقدم الى تماما هل هناك مؤشر يدل على ان
هناك فعلا يعني ضوء في نهايه النفق يعني
ما يجري حاليا لا يدل على ذلك وقد تكون
الحيصيات ويوميات العراق الحربي
تقدم سحابه تحكم الرؤيه وتعتم رؤيه هذا
الضوء الذي يمكن ان يكون في اخر النفق
ولكن اعتقد ان رصيد الحكمه في التاريخ
السياسي السوداني قادر على ان ينتج مبادره
وينتج مساعي تترتب عليها يترتب عليها
ايقاف هذه الحرب والكارثيه بكل الابعاد
فبالتالي اعتقد ان كل التدخلات التدخلات
محموله بانتها الخاصه واصبح هنالك سباق
صراع حتى ما بين الايجاد والاتحاد
الافريقي كان هنالك نزاع واضح حول هذا
الملف هنالك اطراف اخرى تريد ان تدخل ان
تدخل اصابعها في هذا الملف فكلما تكاثرت
هذه الاصابع كلما فسدت كل الحلول
والمقترحات التي تقدم ليس هنالك من خيار
هذه اليغضه التي نشير اليها بان تكون
هنالك حاله غيظه وطنيه عامه في السودان
تفرض على اطراف الصراع
بمراعاه ايضا يقض على الصعيد الافريقي
بشكل عام سيد فهد محمد انت ذكرت ان
المبادرات لم تكن كافيه والتي قدمت حتى
الان ولكن نحن الان بصدد خلافات سودانيه
افريقيه بعدما كنا نحاول ان نحل مشكله
بدانا يعني تظهر ويظهر مدى عمق المشكله
الاكبر في بين الدول الافريقيه بشكل عام
وبين السودان ايضا من ناحيه
فما هو الحل الذي يمكن ان يبدو منطقيا في
هذه المرحله
اعتقد هو جمع كل المبادرات الموجوده حاليا
مبادره اللجان مبادره جدا الولايات
المتحده للاتحاد الاوروبي كلهم يجب ان
يكونوا على قلب رجل واحد في الازمه
السودانيه التي تتفاقم يوم
لا نريد مبادرات كثيره لا حل لها مشاركه
الاتحاد الاوروبي الاتحاد الافريقي نفسه
الولايات المتحده شيء مبشر في هذه القمه
وربما لو كان هناك مبادرات موحده وضغط من
القوى الكبرى على اطراف الصراع لوقف كامل
لاطلاق النار وادخال المساعدات وايجاد حل
سلمي سياسي هذا هو الحل ولكن
نتمنى ان يحل السودانيون مشكلتهم بنفسهم
ولكن لا نرى هذا الى الان تتفاقم الازمه
السودانيه يوما بعد يوم واتحفظ على يعني
ضيفك الكريم عندما ذكر الحرب الاثيوبيه
والرئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي نحن الازمه
السودانيه وعلى السودان ان تتعلم من
التجربه الاثيوبيه لا نريد الشعب السوداني
ان يكون هناك قتله بعدد قتله الاثيوبيين
لا يجب ان ان يعم الامن والسلام في اسرع
وقت والضرر الحاصل في ثلاثه اشهر ربما قد
يؤدي الى كوارث ربما اكثر مما شئت اثيوبيا
في سنتين او ثلاث لذلك
في نظري هو الحل الوحيد هو جمع كل
المبادرات وفي مبادره واحده شامله والضغط
على اطراف الصراع من الولايات المتحده او
من المملكه العربيه السعوديه في الايقاف
الحرب هل يمكن ان تكون هناك جهه تعمل على
تقريب وجهات النظر بهذه الطريقه والتي قد
تبدو ربما شيء يعني من التمنيات في هذه
المرحله هل يمكن فعلا ان يكون هناك الربط
بين كل هذه
الوسطات والمبادرات
نعم اعتقد ذلك والدليل ان هذه الوساطات
شاركت اليوم مع الاجازه هناك وفد امريكي
وفد من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يعني اعتقد انه دليل جيد ويشير الى ان كل
المبادرات
جربت المبادرات الفرديه رايناها ولكنها
مشاركه لم تترجم فعليا على الارض لم تاتي
ثمارها على العموم سنتابع هذا الملف اولا
باول شكرا جزيلا لك فات محمد الباحث في
شان الافريقي من اديس ابابا وشكرا طبعا
لضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب والمحلل
السوداني
محدث في اريتا اتحدث عن المشاكل
والتعقيدات المتعلقه بالايجاد وان ابي
احمد غير مؤهل لتقديم هذه النصائح النتيجه
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لك
لعبت منظمه التي تاسست لاهداف تنمويه
ولمحاربه الجفاف والتصحر ادوار الوساطه في
الصراعات والحروب التي شهدها السودان منذ
عقود
هذه المنظمه جهودها تواجه
صعوبات بسبب موقف الحكومه السودانيه منها
نتابع
استحوذ السودان على جزء كبير من نشاط
منظمه ايجاد منذ تاسيسها عام 96 وبذلت
المنظمه جهودا لانهاء الصراع الدام في
اقليم دارفور منذ عام 2003 وتوسطت في
الصراع بين الشمال والجنوب الذي استمر
سنوات طويله ولم تنتهي المشاكل باستقلال
دوله جنوب السودان عام 2011 استدعى الوضع
الذي ترى ثوره 2019 والانقلاب الذي رافقها
مساهمه ايجاد في جهود اقتسام السلطه بين
المدنيين والعسكريين
الان اصبح الصراع في السودان بين
العسكريين مع ما يحمله ذلك من قوه تدميريه
في بلد انهاكته الحروب والصراعات منذ
اندلاع الصراع اعلنت ايجاد بعد اجتماع
رؤسائها عن مبادره للحل وكلفت رؤساء كينيا
وجنوب السودان والجيبوتي بالعمل لببلوره
حل للنزاع لكن وفد الرؤساء الثلاثه لم يصل
الى الخرطوم بحجه ان الاجواء غير امنه ثم
اعلنت المنظمه مبادره لانهاء النزاع في
السودان وشكلت في يونيو الماضي لجنه
رباعيه برئاسه كينيا وتضم اثيوبيا وجنوب
السودان والصومال رفضت الحكومه السودانيه
في البدايه مبادره ايجاد واعتبرتها مبادره
احتلال لانها تنص على اخلاء العاصمه
الخرطوم من السلاح ونشر قوه افريقيه كما
اعترضت على رئاسه كينيا للجنه الرباعيه
واتهمت رئيسها ويليام روتو بعدم الحياد
ووجود علاقه بينه وبين قوات الدعم السريع
عادت الحكومه السودانيه لقبول مبادره
ايجاد شريطه معها لكنها لم تغير موقفها
الرافده لرئاسه كينيا للجنه الرباعيه ترفض
الحكومه السودانيه رئاسه روتو للجنه
الرباعيه ويرد هو بالمطالبه بقياده قادره
على اخراج السودان من وضعه الحالي
لقد اختتمنا للتوج اجتماع الايكاد بشان
السودان اتفقنا جميعا على ان الوضع بلغ
حدا يرثى له وهذا يتطلب قياده طارئه
وقادره على اخراج السودان من الكارثه
الانسانيه التي يتجه اليها تشكل السودان
احد اهم بلدان منظمه ايجاد الثمانيه ويؤكد
موقعه ان الاحداث التي تجري فيه ستكون لها
اثار سلبيه على المنطقه برمتها ويلقي
الخلاف بين الرئيس الكيني والحكومه
السودانيه اذا استمر بظلال من الشك على
مبادره منظمه ايجاد لحل النزاع في السودان
قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان صاروخين
اطلقا من منطقه جنين باتجاه مستوطنه شاكيد
شماليه ضفه وان الجيش يحقق في الامر كانت
مجموعه تطلق على نفسها كتيبه العياش اعلنت
اطلاق صاروخين محليي صنع من طراز قسام
واحد باتجاه مستوطنه
وبثت الكتيبه على منصه تيليجرام مقطعا
مصورا تقول فيه ان عناصرها استهدفت
المستوطنه وقد طلب الرئيس مجلس مستوطنات
شمال الضفه الغربيه حكومه نتنياهو بشن
عمليه عسكريه اوسع نطاقا من السابقه
عام 2001 ولدت تجربه الفلسطينيين في انتاج
صواريخهم بدات القصه من قطاع غزه بصاروخ
قسام واحد بمدى لا يتجاوز ثلاثه كيلو
مترات استهدف حينها مستوطنه تصديرات في
غلاف القطع بعد 22 عاما يظهر صاروخ قسام
واحد في الضفه الغربيه في استهداف
لمستوطنه شاكيد غرب جنين شماليه الضفه
الغربيه لم تكن هذه المحاوله الاولى
للمقاومه في الضفه الغربيه في تصنيع
الصواريخ واطلاقها خلال الايام الماضيه
اعلنت مجموعه تطلق على نفسها كتيبه العياش
اطلاقها صواريخ باتجاه المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه تقول الكتيبه انها تابعه
لكتاب القسام الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس
بينما لم تتبنى الكتائب هذه العمليات حتى
الان الا ان تصريحات نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي للحركه تشير الى محاولات الحركه
المستمره في هذا الشان نحن قبل ايام اطلق
الصواريخ لاول مره سوف تقسام واحد اطلق من
ايضا من منطقه جنين واحنا يتذكر كل الناس
حين بدات الصواريخ من غزه وقسام واحد كان
يعني هناك من يسخر من الصواريخ
طوالي هذه الاعوام اعتقلت سلطات الاحتلال
عده خلايا حاولت ولم تنجح في الارض يبدو
اطلاق الصواريخ من جنين نجاحا غير مسبوق
للمقاومه في الضفه الغربيه هكذا يصبح
اطلاق الصواريخ من الضفه اكثر رعبا
لاسرائيل لعده اسباب اهمها القرب الجغرافي
وتداخل المستوطنات مع المدن الفلسطينيه ما
يعطي قدره للمقاومه على الضرب بحد ادنى من
القدرات العسكريه بالاضافه الى عدم وجود
قياده واضحه للمقاومه في الضفه يمكن
لاسرائيل التفاوض معها على هدنه توقف
الهجمات الفلسطينيه تلك هجمات تنطلق في
العامين الاخيرين من مدينتي نابلس وجنين
شمالي الضفه
قبل ايام شان الاحتلال حمله عسكريه على
مخيم جنين لاستهداف البنيه التحتيه
للمقاومه وفق ما اعلن للجيش الاسرائيلي
بعد 48 ساعه غدر جيش الاحتلال المخيم دون
تحقيق هدفه من العمليه وفق ما يقول
المقاتلون في المخيم
اولئك خليط من فصائل المقاومه المختلفه في
مقدمتهم الان الكتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا
القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي بالاضافه الى مقاتلين من كتائب
شهداء الاقصى وكتاب القسام واخرين لا
ينتمون الى اي فصيل فلسطيني تقول كتيبه
جنين ان بنيتها التحتيه لا تزال قويه بثت
مشاهد الاستهداف جنود الاحتلال باسلحه لم
تكن في الضفه من قبل تظهر كتيبه العياش
اليوم مقاطع فيديو لتطور نوعي اخر قد يقلب
المعادله هناك
ومن غزه ينضم الان الينا الدكتور صالح
النعامي الباحثه المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي دكتور اهلا وسهلا بك في الحصاد
وابدا معك من يعني دلاله هذه العمليه
الاخيره صاروخين محلياي الصنع
يصيبان منطقه محيطه بمستوطنه
هل لها فعلا دلاله كبيره بالمفهوم العسكري
ما قيمته
اولا هذا مؤشر على بدايه تغيير قواعد
الاشتباك ما بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
والاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه علينا ان
نتذكر ان حيازه المقاومه على قدرات
صاروخيه في الضفه الغربيه هو تغير
استراتيجي من الطراز الاول وهو اخطر بكثير
بكثير من من حيازه المقاومه في قطاع غزه
على هذه القدرات لانه الحديث يدور ليس فقط
عن القرب الجغرافي بل
[موسيقى]
حيازه المقاومه لهذه القوه الصاروخيه
بامكانها ان تستهدف المراكز التجمع
الديموغرافي الاوسع والاكثر كثافه في
اسرائيل انه بالقرب من جنين هناك مدينه
حيفا نتانيا وغيرها من المدن ذات الكثافه
السكانيه العاليه والاكثر من ذلك قربها من
المرافق الحيويه الحساسه التي بامكان
استهدافها ان يفضي الى تغييرات بالغه
الخطوره في اسرائيل هناك مجمع الغاز
في في ميناء حيفا ومجمع البتروكوميات ايضا
بالاضافه للقواعد العسكريه وبالتالي ايضا
هناك تحدي اخر بالنسبه لاسرائيل لانه قدره
المنظومات الدفاع الجوي على اعتراض
الصواريخ بالضبط الغربيه تكون يعني تؤول
الى الصفر لانه هناك مئات المستوطن عشرات
المستوطنات في داخل الضفه الغربيه هناك
مئات المستوى داخل اسرائيل وبالتالي ان
يتمكن جيش الاحتلال من مصر من نصب بطاريات
اعتراض هذه الصواريخ يعني سيكون مضني وغير
فعال وبالتالي اسرائيل ترى في هذا التحول
وان كان كما ذكرت كتيبه العياش انه ياتي
في اطار الاعداد
والتطوير بقدرات المقاومه في الضفه
الغربيه الى ان اسرائيل تنظر اليه يعني
ببالغ الخطوره وبالتالي هذا وماذا بعد
يعني هي التوقيت العمليه ايضا لافت تاتي
بعد ايام فقط من عمليه ج نين التي يعني لم
تجني منها اسرائيل الكثير عسكريا
بالمفهوم الاسرائيلي نفسه والان هي في
مواجهه كتيبه قد تنطلق هنا هناك في اي جزء
من الضفه وقد تصيبها حتى وان كانت لا
تصيبها بشكل كبير عسكريا او ضار او مؤلم
لها ولكن كيف ستتعامل معه
يعني اولا هذا هذا اطلاقا هذه بمناسبه كان
هناك حديث عن عمليات اطلاق صواريخ وقد
اشار اليها نائب رئيس حركه حماس العروري
في تقريركم الذي سبق يعني كان لدى اسرائيل
مؤشرات على على اطلاق صواريخ وان كانت هذا
عمليات اطلق لم تكن ناجحه لكن اطلاق
الصواريخ بعد اسبوع من عمليه ضخمه قامت
بها قام بها جيش الاحتلال في جنين والحق
الضمار الهائل ان تحدث هذه العمليه عن رغم
من ان لدى اسرائيل معلومات حول مثل هذه
الانشطه اندل على شيء فانما يدل على فشل
الرهان الاسرائيلي على خيار القوه في
مواجهه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المقاومه الفلسطيني المتشبث بهذا الخيار
يعني
يطور من قدراته وابداعه بحيث يتجاوز
الاجراءات الاسرائيليه الهادفه الى منع من
تطوير هذه القدرات واطلاق الصواريخ
والاعلان عنها اليوم هذا مؤشر واضح على
صحيح اسرائيل الان ستحاول ان تنشط في
المجال الاستخباري لمعرفه
المكان الذي تم تطوير في هذه الصواريخ
ويمكن ان تعمل الى شان عمليات عسكريه
محدوده
استنادا على معلومات استقباريه ولكن الذي
وضح الان حيازه المقاومه على قدرات علميه
وتقنيه تمكنها من انتاج الصواريخ سيمثل
نقطه يعني لا رجعت منها ولكن سؤالي هل
ستغير اسرائيل في تكتيكها لمواجهه هذا
ستعتمد الان ستحاول الاعتماد على الجانب
الاستخباري الحصول على معلومات استخماريه
تتعلق
الذين يقفون بالضبط عن اطلاق المسؤوليه عن
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ والبنى التنظيميه
الخاصه بهم وايضا هناك خيار
رهان اخر كما تعلمين بالامس اسرائيل يعني
اقرت خطه لتسهيلات لمساعده السلطه
الفلسطينيه
وبالذات من اجل يعني تمكينها من العمل في
شمال الضفه الغربيه وتحديدا في جنين وفي
نابلس وقد يكون هذا جاء في اطار الرهان
الرهان اسرائيل الواضح على دور للسلطه في
المس بقدرات المقاومه في شمال الضفه
الغربيه وتحديدا في جنين اذا كان الصوت
الذي ينادي بالتصعيد مزيد من التصعيد ام
مجرد الاستمرار في الجانب الاستخباري سنرى
من سيفوز على العموم شكرا جزيلا للدكتور
صالح النعامي الباحثه المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه شكرا
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل للجزيره ناقفيله مساعدات امميه
دخلت مناطق شمال غرب سوريا وذلك عبر معبر
باب الهوى والحدودي مع تركيا وقلم مراسلنا
نقلا عن مصادر في المعبر ان القافله هي
الاخيره بموجب القرار الامميه رقم
2672 والذي ينتهي العمل به اليوم تحديدا
ياتي ذلك في وقت تسود فيه اجواء من الترقب
وسط النازحين السوريين شمال البلاد تزامنا
وعقد جلسه لمجلس الامن اليوم للتصويت على
قرار جديد يسمح بادخال المساعدات من معبر
بري واحد هو معبر باب الهوى ودون موافقه
النظام السوري
بالحديث عن الخلافات في مجلس الامن الدولي
بشان فتره تمديد اليه ادخال المساعدات
للشمال السوري نذكر بتلك الاليه
وعملها ومطرء عليها من تغييرات منذ
انشائها قبل تسعه اعوام حاليا ينحصر ادخال
المساعدات الى المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
المعارضه السوريه في معبر باب الهوى
الحدودي كما ذكرنا بين تركيا وسوريا وقد
داب مجلس الامن في السنوات الاخيره على
التمديد سته اشهر فقط رغم مطالبه الامم
المتحده بفتح اكبر عدد ممكن من المعابر
ولمده عام على الاقل نظرا لضخامه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه
الاليه التي تم انشاؤها في 2014 كانت تشمل
سابقا اربعه معابر ولكن ضغوط روسيا والصين
حصرتها في معبر باب الهوى فقط كما خفضت
مده التفويض الى سته اشهر بدلا من عام كما
هو المطلب تلك المعابر هي معبر باب
السلامه الحدودي
وهذا يربطها مع تركيا والذي سمح النظام
السوري بفتحه استثنائيا حتى منتصف اغسطس
المقبل بعد مناشدات الامم المتحده وذلك
خلال الزلزال الاخير اضافه الى معبر
اليعروبيه
والذي يقع شرقا على الحدود مع العراق
ومعبر ايضا الرمثا الحدودي جنوبا مع
الاردن
طبعا التمديد لا ينهي قلق الامم المتحده
والجهات الاغاثيه لان احتياجات الشمال
السوري تفوق ما يمكن ان يوفره معبر واحد
وخلال سته اشهر فقط
استنادا الى احصاءات الامم المتحده تضم
تلك المناطق حاليا نحو اربعه ملايين ونصف
المليون سوري اكثر من نصفهم نازحون من
مناطق اخرى وذلك بسبب الحرب
من بين اولئك اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين شخص
يعانون انعدام الامن الغذائي لاسيما
النساء والاطفال
كما يعيش نحو مليوني شخص في مخيمات وقد
تفخم الوقت والوضع اكثر مع الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب المنطقه في فبراير الماضي
اذا الان نناقش هذه التطورات مع ضيفنا من
واشنطن
كبير الباحثين في معهد واشنطن لسياسات
الشرق الادنى والمختص في الشؤون السوريه
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد تابلر اذا ما هي اهم
العقبات التي تواجه الوضع السوري المتازم
واي محاوله لتحسيله برايك الان
اعتقد ان العرقل الاساسيه في سوريا الان
هو غياب حل للحرب ليس هناك اليه لحل هذا
الموضوع بعد
القرار 22 واربعين
وبالتالي
هذا يعني ان هذا يتطلب تحركا اماميا عاده
من خلال التصويت طريقه منفصله من اجل سماح
بتدفق المساعدات الانسانيه الى مناطق
تسيطر عليها المعارضه في شمال وغرب سوريا
ولكن ليس فقط هناك اعتقد ان هذه اكبر
مشكله في موضوع المساعدات الانسانيه
ويمكن
ايصال اذا المساعدات الانسانيه الى
المنطقه التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه ولكن
ايضا هناك عرقله بالنسبه المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها النظام الاسد فيما يتعلق
بتقديم الرعايه الحقيقيه والضروريه
للمدنيين السوريين ولكن فيما يتعلق
بالمدنيين السوريين سواء ما شاهدناه في
الزلزال اما ما يحصل الان لماذا عندما
ياتي الامر بهؤلاء يصبح الموضوع معقد لهذه
الدرجه اليس هناك جهه تستطيع ان تدفع
لتحرك الامور حتى يتوقف هذا
الالم والوضع القاسي المستمر كل هذه
السنوات
هذا سؤال وجيه انا لست اكيد من ان الجواب
قد يكون سهلا
لقد تدخلت اطراف مختلفه في الحرب
السوريه من روسيا وايران
وتركيا والولايات المتحده واسرائيل
ولكن حقيقه الامر هي ان كل هذه الاطراف
لا تريد فعلا اتخاذ الخطوات الضروريه من
اجل ضمان الاستقرار في البلاد باسرها
وبالتالي هي لا يهمها ولا ترضى سوى بجزء
من البلاد وبالتالي ما يحصل هو انها عمليه
التصويت تحصل كل سته اشهر او سنه
وفجاه تعود قد سوريا مطروحه وواضح للجميع
انها لم تحل وهناك مناقشات اليوم حول او
مناقشات اليوم حول موضوع
عبور المساعدات الانسانيه لحدود تظهر ان
الازمه لم تنتهي ولكن واضح سيد تبلغ ان
هناك تغيرات في العلاقات الدوليه يعني
اعداء الامس بداوا على الاقل
على ما يبدو شيء من التفاهم لا نريد ان
نقول انهم اصبحوا اصدقاء ولكن هناك تغير
واضافه الى ما خلته الحرب الاوكرانيه وما
يجري حاليا في ليتوانيا من اجتماع كيف
يمكن لكل هذا ان يلعب دور في التاثير على
هذا الملف تحديدا
هذا النوع من النقاشات من شانها ان تخفف
من التوترات
وتتيح
بعض التلاقي ولو مؤقتا بينها بعض الاطراف
هذا لا يؤدي الى حل المشاكل التي ادت الى
الحرب السوريه او التي تاتت عن الحرب
السوريه ولا يؤدي الى ذلك بالضروره احد
اكبر العراقيل مثلا هو استمرار نظام الاسد
برفض تقديم اي تنازلات بالنسبه الى توصل
لاي حل طالما ان هذا مستمر
وطالما ان المعارضه تسيطر على اجزاء
مختلفه من البلاد سوف لن تحل هذه الازمه
ستبقى مستدامه وستقرر الموضوع كل فتره
وسنوجه وضعا طبقه لنا ان واجهنا حين نتعلق
الامر بعبور الحدود شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
تبلغ شكرا لك من واشنط
[موسيقى]
ننهي الحصاد بقضيه اشعرت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي قضيه حصلت في لبنان ولكنها ممكن
ان تحصل في اي مكان ليس فقط في العالم
العربي انما في العالم كله ليس هناك اب او
ام لم يتاثر بالصور التي شاهدناها ولكن
السؤال اين الضمير وايضا السؤال لماذا لم
يكن هناك مراقبه اليوم نحن محظوظين لاننا
نعيش في عالم فيه وسائل تواصل اجتماعي كل
شخص يملك هاتف ذكي حتى لو كان عاملا بسيطا
ليس هناك اي حدود علينا مسؤوليه نحن كاباء
وامهات ان نراقب علينا مسؤوليه ان لا نترك
اطفالنا عرضه لمصير كهذا سواء كانوا في
البيوت او في دور الرعايه شكرا جزيلا لكم
ودمتم بخير وبامان
[موسيقى]